المحادثه بين الرئيسين تستند من دون شكله
تقارب متسارع الوتيره بين موسكو وبكين منذ
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا يبدو الرئيس
الصيني تشجن في بعض الاحيان بشان العمليه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا رئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين اقر ذلك علنا في سبتمبر ايلول
الماضي بان نظيره الصيني لديه قلق بشان
تحركات روسيا في لقاء جمعهما في فبراير
الماضي على هامش دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه
الشتويه التي اقامتها بكين قال بوتين ان
علاقاته الثنائيه مع الصين تطورت في ظل
صداقه وشراكه استراتيجيه غير مسبوقه
علاقات اقتصاديه وسياسيه وامنيه ساعات
موسكو الى تعميقها مع بكين منذ سنه حربها
في اوكرانيا بعد هذا اللقاء ب 20 يوما
كذلك
تطمح موسكو وبكيني لتشكيل قوه جيو سياسيه
في مواجهه الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
واجرتها عمليه عسكريه مشتركه في الاشهر
الاخيره ابرزها مناورات بحريه هذا الاسبوع
في بحر الصين الشرقي 9 موسكو ايضا الى
زياده الصادراتها من الغاز للاقتصاد
الصيني الشديد لاستهلاك الطاقه وبذلات
جهودا حديثا في هذا الصدد روسيات تواجه
ازمه حاده مع الغرب بسبب اوكرانيا تخضع
لعقوبه اقتصاديه وخفضت كذلك صادرات
المحروقات الى اوروبا لاجئه الى اسيا
لتعويض هذا النقص وتعتزم روسيا اعتبارا من
2020 بناء خط انابيب قوه سبيريا اثنان
لامداد بكين بالغاز عبر منغوليا في مؤشرين
اضافي الى المنحه المختلفه نحو الشرق في
استراتيجتها للطاقه